foreign
Tallahassee what's up Anna
hey how are you partying what are you
doing
I'm actually home with covet so not much
to do now oh gosh I'm not laughing at
you I'm just laughing like oh that's no
good
yeah I know I actually just traveled
outside of the country and that's what I
get so here we are
that's what you get some kind of cosmic
punishment you will stay in America
I haven't read the latest um literature
hopefully I can't catch it over the
phone like this
Anna if you give me covet I'm gonna be
not happy with you okay let's do this
what's up
the question was I want to understand
why I'm choosing a life of misery
um my email was very vague but uh just a
little background I'm 25 years old I'm
almost two under two
um and a husband uh you know been
married since 2019 however he's been in
my life since I was 15.
um so we I want to say we kind of grew
up together
um however
I'm at a point in my life where I have
undiagnosed you know depression anxiety
um how do you know
well I started going to a therapist and
she said hey I think this is what you
have so it's not undiagnosed it is
diagnosed
well counselors I mean counselors and
mental health professionals of all kind
are I mean they've got to go through
their licensure so you've been
officially diagnosed if if a licensed
mental health professional said you have
this which again I hate that language
with all my guts I hate that language
but if they told you you ever this then
you've got a diagnosis okay so they said
you've got anxiety and depression
[Music]
and then be a therapist or anything
before
um however had children and I feel like
that kind of postpartum depression kind
of may have you know
made it more pronounced
um and so going through all that with
them
um that's that's how they ended with
that conclusion
um
so so hold on before we go further
before we go further I want you to hear
me say something really important for
you okay in a million years I'm not
going to dispute what your person told
you okay
rest on that if they're a licensed
professional and they know what they're
doing and they're not just out there
running and gunning and being idiots
cool
and
imagine what's your favorite movie of
all time
um
Forrest Gump imagine you're watching all
of Forrest Gump
and there's that scene when he's running
and you took your phone and you snapped
a photo of him running
that is your diagnosis it's not the
whole movie
it's a snapshot of your life and
actually if you just looked at this
picture of a bearded man running
you would think the movie is about
something very different than what it
actually is about right
right okay so this is not your destiny
this is not the rest of your life this
is not a a
confirmed death sentence
okay
this is a series of experiences that
you've been having for an for a period
of time and somebody says all right
took a picture here's where we are right
now
okay okay
[Music]
um
yeah
and with that being said
uh my escorts of seven
um and I have some childhood trauma that
is still there
um that I have that probably probably
um so with you know
um we've talked a little bit about it in
counseling I've mentioned that but it
still comes up a lot
um
and so now
I'm at a point where
I wake up every day I do what I need to
do however
there's no time for me there's
um priorities that take precedence over
me and
how do I
choose me and
I put my kids first
um
because of the mom you know that as soon
as they were born they took priority
um
and
yeah I just I don't know how to
be happy and make the decisions I need
to make
and create a better life not only for
them but for me yeah
and growing up was really hard
right you've got Aces score of seven
that means you grew up in a in a blender
yeah and your body's been through some
pretty awful things huh
oh yeah yeah
a couple of things at play here number
one I just want to call out the obvious
you've been with your husband for a long
time I think you used the words we grew
up together
okay
what that means is without him realizing
it I'm not saying he's a bad guy
I'm saying any time
you rise up you begin thinking about
healing you begin to alter the dynamic
the homeostatic relationship between you
and him
his body gets out of whack
and it wants things to go back the way
they were
and so your healing
your I'm sick and tired of being sick
and tired I've had enough
is going to have to include him
and he is going to have to be along for
the ride
meaning your healing is going to be
disruptive to him and it should be and
that's the way things are going to be
okay
okay here's why I'm telling you that
first you cannot do this by yourself
and you can't do it without
Rippling the water
somebody with an Asus score of seven
ninety nine hundred and
what's the word 999 times out of a
thousand
got really good
at making sure everybody else was okay
that's how you survived
Fair
yeah
so much so that you've outsourced that
to uh
19 month old and a
four month old
I gotta make sure they're okay then I
can exhale I gotta make sure he's okay
then I can exhale
and so for instance here's a simple
thing let's say you decide like I'm
gonna I I want to lose weight and I want
to be healthy
and for two nights you cook healthy
foods you go for a walk after dinner
he's gonna show up with a pizza
on night three
not for any reason other than he's
driving home and he's like man my wife's
been doing really good the last two days
eating healthy like she deserves some
joy in her life
and then we're back to the way things
were okay so this is gonna be disruptive
I want you to get that through your
heart and through your mind
number two
I get a sense from you that you go to a
counselor and you just talk about stuff
I want you to start going to counseling
and if this isn't the right therapist I
want you to find the right one with a
spirit of I'm going to work
I'm not going just to talk about this
stuff
because quite frankly Anna you have had
these conversations in your mind for
your whole life right
yeah yeah
I want you to go to counseling with a
spirit of
a sledgehammer and a lunch pail I'm
going to break concrete I'm going to do
some hard work
okay okay
yeah tell me you've never seen this in
real life so this is all fantasy at this
point
describe to me what you want your body
to feel like when you walk home fast
forward three years
you've got
um I don't know you might have nine
other kids by then at your rate just
kidding so you've got
um
three years from now you've done a lot
of counseling you and your husband have
reimagined your marriage and you walk in
the front door
just tell me what you would imagine that
would feel like
um
like happiness no happiness is happiness
is cotton candy and cocaine happiness is
just a high five on the trail to
wherever it is you're going
happy don't don't don't reach for
happiness that can't be your destination
okay because you're gonna it's got too
many off-ramps you know it would make me
really happy right now a bag of gummy
candy and a Diet Coke that'd be so
awesome
and it would make me feel terrible it
would make me really short-tempered and
it would make me really want to
procrastinate these book edits and I
gotta get done and you know what I'm
saying and and
happy is when I wake up and I've had a
good night of sleep and I've taken care
of my body and my wife and I are in sync
and my kids are I can hear the Milling
around out laughing with each other and
I smile and I think I'm really happy
right now
but that can't be the objective okay so
you walk in the front door what do you
feel
um
I want to say good
um all right close your eyes let's do
this close your eyes okay okay you walk
through your front door
you hear one of your knuckleheaded kids
go Mom's home
and they get up and they run and they
squeeze your legs as hard as they can
and you're smiling ear to ear
you guys don't owe anybody any money
your kids are healthy
you feel good because you had a good
night's sleep
and you say all right get off get off
and they laugh and one of them shoves
the other one then they run out into the
backyard to go play
and then your husband walks out of his
back room
and he smiles real big and he says I'm
so glad you're home he drops his
shoulders and you all hug for a minute
when I say what does it feel like I'm
thinking of warmth and I'm thinking of
laughter and I'm thinking of peace and
I'm thinking of
who yes
you've never had that walking into a
house before have you
no no
I want you that I can I want you to have
that more than anything in the world
and I need you to believe me on the
front end of this journey 100 you can
get there
okay here's what it's gonna look like
understanding this radical truth your
kids can only be fully taken care of if
Mom's okay
so the best way to put your kids forward
is by taking care of their mom
now you got really young ones of course
you're gonna be exhausted you're gonna
get up in the middle of the night you
get a million diapers just getting them
in and out of the freaking bathtub is
chaos right
right that's the season you're in it's
not smooth sailing for a while it's okay
I promise you man when they can go to
the bathroom on their own and get in out
of the shower it's like you got half
your life back it's amazing but that's
not you right now it's okay
okay so we're gonna take this season and
we're not going to say things like
I don't have any time to take care of me
we're gonna say things like I chose not
to take care of myself today
and we're going to start using that kind
of language
because then we're going to be able to
say I'm choosing to take care of myself
today
hey honey I'm getting up a little bit
early to go for a walk only 15 minutes
but I'm gonna go for a walk
hey honey I'm gonna get an app out and I
don't know how to meditate because that
sounds stupid but I'm just gonna sit
here and close my eyes put the
headphones in and just follow with those
things the breathing exercises things
tell me to do
I need you to go watch the little ones
cool
hey honey once a week going to do a
budget with you just talk about calendar
because I have this picture in my head
where you and I can't wait to see each
other
and it's warm
and it's peaceful
and then when you go talk to a counselor
you're gonna have to be honest about
your childhood and you haven't done that
yet
give him hard and you've talked around
the bush but you you have not
said here's what happened to me
right
right because if you say it out loud
then you have to deal with the
ramifications of the people who should
have been there to help you weren't
there or they may have been part of the
problem
yeah this journey gets hard
okay
okay and you're worth every freaking
step of it Anna okay one more thing I'm
gonna tell you I want you to make a list
on a note card
or on a piece of paper or maybe you're
crafty and you can make it look nice I
don't know how so I just gave up
okay but I want you to put five or ten
things action steps that you do every
day
that your feelings don't get a vote on
your motivation doesn't get a vote you
will do these things
I will go for a walk
I will put my hands on my kids face and
look them in the eye and kiss them on
the forehead for 30 seconds each kid
even the wiggly one
I will do four rounds of I don't know 10
seconds 15 seconds of skin on skin
contact with my husband
right when we wake up right before I
leave for work right when we get home
right before we go to sleep
can just be touched it didn't have to be
sexual just be I'm just gonna Touch Feet
I'm gonna hold his hand
I'm gonna put my hand on his chest and
put my face on his face I'm just gonna
sit here for a second
I want you to write these things down
and I don't care if you don't feel like
it I don't care if he comes home and
he's gross and he does something stupid
I gotta get my fourth skin on skin
contact
okay feelings don't matter what we're
going to do is we're building a new
muscle that you don't you've never had
to deal to build before
and that is discipline that is I'm worth
this even when I don't feel like it I
love myself even when myself doesn't
feel like loving me back
that's what I'm going to take care of it
okay
okay promise
yeah I'm already running I'm down yeah I
know you would because you're done
aren't you you're done with all this
yeah
hey hey I'm so so proud of you
thank you an aces of seven means you
have been through hell
and after you go through hell and you're
covered up in all these scars and you
still have stitches and burn marks
sometimes putting your hand up and
saying hey I need help
raising your hand in the old days gotcha
gotcha hit
I got you seen
so just the act of raising your hand and
saying
I'm sick and tired of being sick and
tired as an act of rebellion it's an act
of Courage that says hold on hold on
I'm worth being loved too
I'm done with surviving
I'm done with hating myself I'm done
with being covered up in shame all the
time it's time to be free
got a hard road ahead of you Anna it'll
be tough
and you are worth every single step and
by the way your kids are gonna get to
watch their mama
get six inches taller
this is changing her family tree your
kids are gonna get to watch you and your
husband argue and try to
move this way this way and develop
boundaries and say no to your family and
his family and all and figure out a new
way marriage is going to work they get
to see all that this is changing your
family tree
so proud of you Anna